computer. All right, sounds like we got
quite a few folks signed up today. I'm
really excited to talk about 12 factor
agents. How many of you read the blog
post? Did everyone read it so far that
Dexter made?
Nope. Oh, you're you're in for a real
treat. The gonna be a good time. One of
the one of the most fun blog posts I've
read in a while. Um,
and it's this interesting concept that
we had percolated on for quite a while
and then Dexter just put it down to like
these beautiful words to really help
outline it in a more concrete way.
Well, yeah, I
think I kind of stumbled on this. We did
I think you and me did a hackathon back
in like October or November and we were
building agents and we were building
them from
scratch. Uh, and that was kind of the
seed and the the initial idea there that
I then went and hacked on and talked to
a ton a ton of founders
and was just trying to trying to figure
out what makes what makes good agents
and like how can we how can we can
distill this down into building blocks.
Yeah. Yeah. Like the building blocks I
think are that's really what's missing
right now.
Well, and and so the problem with with
not having good building blocks, I
think, is you I know we said we're going
to wait till people got here, but I'm
just going to start going. The problem
with not having good building blocks is
I think you end up with this problem of
you're like, "Oh, I want to build
something pretty cool with AI. I want to
build something agentic. I want to do
something a little bit more than just a
chatbot or uh, you know, summarization
in my web app." And and so you're like,
"Cool, we need an agent." like okay like
I don't want to write all this code from
scratch really learn it all from
scratch. Uh maybe you do, some people
do, but a lot of folks are like, "Cool,
let's go get some frameworks and some
libraries." And I think what it leads
you down this path of like, "Hey, let's
build rather than like just making our
existing software a little more AI
integrated." You end up
with people who are just like, "Hey,
let's go build something from scratch.
Let's we're building our agent. We're
gonna we have our thing now and we're
going to go do green field from scratch.
Build an agent." And uh I think what
happens
is that never works. And what I wanted
to figure out was like how can I help
people who already have really good
software and have ideas about how how AI
could make it better
and what what things did they need to
take from the agent
paradigm that they can take one by one
that they can take peace meal that they
can kind of like just carve up this
problem and slowly over time take
deterministic code and sprinkle in some
LLM calls in the right places to make it
really man like magical without tanking
the quality or making it unreliable or
having this sort of like chat GPT
hallucination effect where like one in
five times you're like, "Oh, this is
useless. This is never going to work."
Yeah, I agree. Let's um All right, it's
104. Let's do a quick little brief
background who we are um to everyone
that's on the call and then let's get
into it and like what this thing is
about. So, cool. Um I'm Vibe. I'm one of
the co-creators of BAML. Um, I'm a YC
founder from Winter 23 and uh this is my
co-host, I guess.
Uh, go for
it. Uh, what's up? I'm Dex. Uh, I'm the
founder of uh, Human Layer, uh, another
YC company. Uh, we are working on um,
safer, more reliable agents and, uh, how
to build agents that can actually get
real, meaningful work done. And uh yeah,
and the whole point series that we've
got here is really just we all see a lot
of demos that come with AI and we'd like
to go past the demo stage. We've seen uh
between Dex and I, we've seen like
probably hundreds of companies that have
actually shipped to production and found
patterns that work and we've found our
own techniques that work and we just
want to use this session to go share
some of those and not really at a high
level, but really at the layer of code
because honestly, it's just there's a
lot of things that talk about the the
words behind the AI, but there's not a
lot of stuff that talks about the code
that we have to go write and that's the
whole point of these sessions. So, as
you guys have any questions, um, please
go ahead and post them in the chat or if
you really want, you're welcome to
unmute and go ask questions as you go.
What we're going to go do is typically
we include a whiteboard session and then
we also include some coding sessions
because whiteboards are just a great way
to convey ideas before the code. Um, so
be patient. You will see code, we
promise. Um, but also the whiteboarding
is just to help contextualize and make
sure we're on the same page.
Cool. Awesome. Let's get today's session
I think. Let's get into it. Um little
preface. There will be some um question.
Okay, let's go on. That's Let's go. All
right, we're gonna keep rolling. Let's
go into 12 factory. You want to screen?
Yep. I'm gonna screen share and um
there's gonna be a little bit less uh
what I would call
um let's
see a little bit less of what I would
call the like hands-on live
whiteboarding just because there's a lot
a lot a lot of content to cover. Um and
so I'm going to jump through kind of a
little bit more of a slideshow kind of
thing, but this is all the content in
the repo. You can see all of this. Um,
so I want to start with kind of like a
little bit of like how we got here and
how to think about writing code in
software. Um, and this is a concept
here, this like software is a directed
graph. Um, because there's a lot of like
frameworks today that help you think in
graphs, but at the end of the day, code
is a graph. And the theme we're going to
keep coming back to here is you want to
have control over the code. You want to
have hands in the code because that's
what gives you the control to add probes
and changes and tests and things to help
you improve the quality. Um after a
while we ended up with these things we
call like DAG orchestrators. If you're
familiar with your like prefects or your
airflows or your um dagsters, these
sorts of things where each one of these
nodes it's still a directed graph. You
still have logic that is moving
information whether it's variables or
data in a pipeline through different
steps. Uh and it's very declarative and
deterministic.
Um, the promise of agents is essentially
like the the real hype around agents is
you can take an LLM, you can give it a
bag of tools, you can say like here's
all the steps you could take. I'm not
going to tell you which steps to take
and which order to do it in, but here's
your goal and here's the steps you can
take
and like go figure it out basically. And
that the LM will traverse the graph,
figure out which steps to take in which
order and get to that goal. And it might
skip some steps as well. I might not
need to take all the steps. And the idea
here is cool, now I have to write a lot
less software. Whether it's like a DAG
that is in code or it's a DAG that's in
my infrastructure. Conceptually, the
agent's going to figure out the ifs and
the logic and the and the looping for me
instead of me having to go write all of
that and test it and make sure it's
really really good. And as LM get
smarter, they'll be able to handle more
and more complex workflows.
Um, and the way we model this, um,
especially when we talk about like
agents, um, and structured outputs is
essentially like an agent is just a
prompt that determines a next step. And
so you have an event and you say, "Hey,
LM, what's the next step with this
event?" And then the LM might say,
"Okay, we have to call this API or we
have to kick off this pipeline or we
have to update this database." Um, or
maybe it's like, "Cool, we're done.
We've done those things and now and now
we're finished." And just and the way
this kind of Sorry, go ahead. Just to
really highlight to a lot of people,
it's like a lot of people use this word
of like the agent is calling the tool.
It's not calling the tool. An
LLM is really just a really really smart
go-to statement. Like in our code, we
used to write goto statement. That's
really all this boils down to. I love
that you said goto because I literally
have a blog post I want to write that is
like do do you remember that post that
was uh goto considered harmful? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. It's Yeah. What an LM is. So
uh I I actually think the concept of
tool use is harmful. The idea that a
model is smart and is interacting with
its environment is actually like it's a
little bit of hype. I mean it's you can
think about it in that way and it's a
good way to like introduce the concept
but at the end of the day when a model
calls a tool it's taking a bunch of a
bunch of input tokens as the prompt and
maybe some tokens about what's happened
so far and it's outputting JSON that
says I think the next step in this
workflow is X. We should play the one.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So the way this
works as you kind of uh move through
this stuff is
um you would you would kind of like pick
a step, call an API, and then add that
to the context window, feed that new
context window in. It says, "Okay, we
had this event, we called this API, we
got a result." Then the LM is going to
say like, "Okay, cool. With that result,
I can now kick off a pipeline and get
the result of that." And then we add
that to the context window. We feed it
back into the LLM and we then we update
the database and we get the result. And
then then we add that to the context
window. And then the LLM may say, "Cool,
we've done our job." Based on the event,
based on the goal, based on this is
super generic, but every time you do a
tool calling. And if you've built these
tool calling loops with the OpenAI APIs
or the anthropic APIs, like this, this
will seem super familiar. We just want
to break this down conceptually into,
you know, what is um what is this
really? Um, what's the shortcut for
opening the file browser? Command B.
Command B. I'm trying that. Yeah, there
we go. Okay, cool. Thank you. Uh so in
this kind of like uh dynamic loop what
was materialized is this DAG right the
agent figured out the DAG for us. We did
this step and then we did this step and
then we did this step and uh at the end
of the day that's that's kind of that's
kind of what happened. Um if we come
back to this loop there's basically four
components right you have
uh you have a prompt and then the
prompt's going to output JSON. You have
a switch statement which is going to
basically say based on the JSON that was
output which code path do we want to go
down or do we want to exit and then you
have how you're building how you tell
the model again because this is totally
stateless. The only way it knows what
happened in the past is if you p pass in
tokens strings JSON XML whatever it is
uh and tell it what happened before so
it can make the decision of the next
step and then you have a for loop. The
whole idea behind 12 factor agents is
really like you're a good
engineer. I hope probably you can write
a switch statement. You can write a for
loop and you can turn some data into a
string. And the most important part
that's going to control how good your
agent is and how good the performance is
is this prompt. The prompt of how to
behave, how to do it. what's the context
that we put in and how to call these
tools, the description of the JSON that
you're asking it to output. And I I want
to highlight one thing here. A lot of
people just I I know what you mean when
you say prompt, but I think a lot of
people are going to assume that prompt
means a system prompt all the stuff.
That is not what Dexture means. Just to
highlight that again, what Dexter are
trying to say is it's the full
serialization of the state. We talked
about this determine next step being
completely stateless. Yeah. Context that
you're putting into it. Somehow you turn
that context into a where are you going
to the whiteboard? Someow you're going
to turn that context into a string.
Somehow you're going to include
instructions for what you want the model
to do. Somehow you're going to model the
exact outputs you want the model to
output. All of those things together are
the prompt. It is not individualistic.
It is not simply to say exactly what the
system prompt is. It is everything
together. That is what Dexter is trying
to highlight of what the prompt is. And
even here where you we're using the word
system and user prompt because that's
just terminology people have used. You
may find that putting the entire context
into the pure system prompt is going to
get you the best response. You may find
putting instructions in the user prompt
gets you the best response. Even that
itself, whether you use the system
prompt or the user prompt or what tokens
you're using to represent this
dramatically makes a difference. And
being aware of that fact of like what
you're what you're doing here is somehow
you're taking a data model that you have
that represents a state that you save in
your database and turning it into an API
call that matches the best output format
that you want somehow. That's and the
point and the point is not to kind of
say there's a right way to do this or
there's a right thing to do here. The
point is if you think of this whole
thing as just one big string. You can do
anything you want with this. And I don't
know what the best way to handle the
prompt for your specific problem. But I
know that if you don't have full control
over what goes in there in what order
with what special tokens, you may be
missing out on optimizations that you
could make. And so the more control you
have, the more ability you have to
customize all of this and to take full
control, the more likely you're going to
be able to get to the best performance
for a given task that a model could get.
And that's all that we talk about in
this show is how do we get the best
possible performance out of today's
models. Yeah, that's perfect. Yeah, and
we'll get into kind of as the models get
smarter as well, but um I'm going to
quickly run through the 12 factors as we
talk about them and we may pause on a
couple of them to go a little bit
deeper, but um from there from there
we'll get into some code. So, uh number
one is like natural language uh becoming
tool calls. And this one's really really
straightforward, but it's basically, you
know, taking words from a human and
turning them into JSON. That's all we're
going to do. We'll go through this in
the in the in in the demo. Uh, but being
able to take human human words and turn
them into actions in the world.
Uh, Carlos has a question. Does that
mean ditch the frameworks? We'll talk
about we'll talk about frameworks in a
second. Yeah, we'll have a second coming
out about Nobody here is saying ditch
the frameworks. I actually think of a
lot of this year as like feature
requests or like a letter to the
builders of frameworks of like the kinds
of control knobs that I think they
should be exposing.
Um, factor two is own your prompts. This
is what we just talked about. Basically,
like rather than building abstractions
around something that's going to build
you a great prompt, you can hit a
framework like Langchain, like Crua,
they all have really, really good prompt
engineering primitives built in. And if
you're not a good prompt engineer like
me, I'm a shitty prompt engineer. You'll
you'll see Fibb shout at me for my
prompts later today. Uh you can turn
some like highle sentences into a banger
prompt, which like you'd need months to
go to prompt school to learn. I don't
know if there's a prompt school, but bye
Bob if you're thinking of other schools
to do. Um
uh but
eventually like with the blackbox,
you're going to hit the limits and
you're going to be reverse engineering.
Okay, how does this prompt get built and
how do I flip these tokens around so
that it happens in the order that I
think is actually going to be better?
And so at the end of the day, it's
really just worth like full ownership.
Yeah, it's just like any it's not an
additional framework, but you really
want you don't you probably don't want
to build a prompt from raw strings on
your own, but you also don't want a
framework that makes it harder for you
to own the prompt. That's really what I
would look for. like how closely do you
own the prompt and how much control do
you have over the final prompt that is
being sent out? Yeah. And again, this is
I don't know what's better, but I know
you want to be able to try everything.
Yeah.
Um, cool. The other one is own your
context building. This is you know when
we say prompt like this is a kind of a
subset of that but it's a very
specialized one because I think a lot of
people uh think of tool calling and
context building as separate from
prompting but it's all just tokens going
into the model. So if you want to use
the standard format of like system user
assistant tool assistant tool and like
you're giving it back and forth in this
official format you could do that. But
in this moment when you're giving the
model a prompt, your only job is to tell
the model what happened so far and ask
it what the next step should be. And you
can put all of the events of like, hey,
what's the weather in Tokyo? Hey, we did
a check weather call. Hey, we got a
response. Ask the next step. And then we
would probably get our final answer. You
can do that all in one user message if
it works better. And I don't know what's
better. Every model is a tool calling
model is the way to think about it. As
long as you can describe your tools in a
good way.
Yes, exactly. Um, tools are just
structured output. We're going to these
are a lot of these are clearly like
related and and come together. Um, but
whether you're telling OpenAI with a
JSON schema to output certain tool to
output a function call to a certain
function or you're using something like
BAML to just ask it to output JSON
plane. Um it's all just part of the
prompt and then what you do with the
output and parsing it and turning it
into structured data for your model to
use. Um let's find this one. Yeah. So
all you have to do is get JSON out of
the model. And so thinking about this in
terms of special tools or special
functions is is can be can be sometimes
a little bit uh counterproductive. Yeah.
Instead of calling a tool, it's just
honestly way easier to say it's a type
that I want the model to produce. I want
the model to return a class. I want the
model to return an array instead of
using the special word tool because we
have tooling for all the other things
pipe systems in the past. Yep. Um, cool.
Here's another one. Uh, unify execution
state and business state. I'm actually
going to do the animation for this one.
Um but basically you know as you are
iterating through this flow and you have
your different JSON outputs um being
able to serialize what's happened so far
your context window that you're passing
into the model
um is not just like the business state
of what is the model thinking about and
what the logic is but you can if you can
you should trivially like make the
context window itself be a
representation of your execution state
as Well, a lot of these frameworks like
uh if you look at something like um lang
graph which I I think is very good for a
lot of reasons but you have kind of two
states here. You have the graph state
and then you have the like uh like the
object that flow you have your business
state right you have like the object
that flows through the graph and this is
usually like some strruct that is just
like messages and it's a list of
messages and you can store other things
on here as well like you know pending
tool calls or something like that.
Um, but basically your like business
state of what what the model operates on
is separate from this big I don't have a
screenshot of it, but there's this huge
like a bunch of tables that go into
SQLite or Postgress or whatever it is
that kind of outline every single step
that's been taken. If you can unify
these things, you're going to simplify a
lot. There may still be reasons to have
this. And this gets back into like own
your context window. If you have an
object that you control that tracks like
the state of your application, you can
put methods on it that tell, hey, when
we send to the model, just send it this
way, like here's how you serialize this
for the LM versus here's how you
serialize this for rag versus here's how
you actually like use this to pump the
execution state. Um so it's again it's
all about control but if you unify those
things then you can get uh you can get a
lot of simplicity and you can get this
is what a lot of people are doing in
terms of just like I think building AI
agents in production. Go ahead. The best
analogy for this kind of stuff is I
don't know if any of you have ever
worked on like massively online
multiplayer games, but like the way you
build these systems is that they're
built to have a unified state of source
of tree and then you basically use that
everyone views and renders.
You view that as the thing that everyone
that builds and renders and that's just
the easiest. If you have like seven
different objects that reference the
source of truth, you have discrepancies,
you have untruths and you you have a
really hard time representing the data.
But if you have a single state,
debugging and everything else building,
maintaining our systems becomes a lot
easier and that simplicity is really
really important. Yeah, nailed it. Um,
cool. We're gonna keep running again.
Uh, what this lets you do is you can
pause and resume with like very simple
APIs. So as you're running through this
workflow and your model is maybe you
know you launch a workflow over rest or
MCP and that causes some kind of context
to be input into the model maybe it
calls a longunning tool and you need to
kind of like interrupt or pause your
workflow that's great store your context
in the database and the fact that you've
most recently called a longunning tool
and then basically when the job is
finished you would post a web hook back
use that to pull the state out of the
database and then take the result and
push it onto the thing and send it back
into the model. Man, I wish that thing
paused. I think this is it. Yeah. So,
essentially like resume later using a
state ID that tells it how to pull the
context out of the database and then you
take the job result. And so you can
build if you own this logic here, this
API endpoint, you can catch a web hook,
you can reassemble the context from the
past, you can append the result to it,
push it right back into the model, and
there's no other execution system.
There's no, you know, distributed
workflow system that you also have to go
integrate into because all we care about
is our context window. Exactly. And
because it's a stateless function, it
doesn't matter. It's really easy to make
everything work. Yeah. LMS are
stateless. The only Yeah. The only state
is basically this context window, which
is also nice because it's very
inspectable. Like as a human, you can
look at it and see, okay, here's what's
happening. Here's where it got stuck.
Here's where it's looping on an error,
whatever it is. Exactly. And as a
developer, that means you can build UIs
for your tool, for your customers as
well to see exactly what's happening on
a long running async task. Yeah. Um,
this one's subtle. I think we could do a
whole 20 minute on just this one. But um
basically when a model is making a
decision about whether to output a tool
call or whether to output plain text,
there's like a very very like
highweighted like token choice which is
like the JSON token or the I'm going to
contact a human token
um and or sorry not contacting you but
I'm gonna output my answer that goes to
the chat UI or wherever wherever it is.
And um what I've seen a lot of people
doing is one there are different reasons
you might want to send a note to a human
whether it's like requesting
clarification or a final answer. And
there's also different like types of
humans a model might want to contact.
And if you want like better AI
experiences you need something you need
to give the model the option to involve
multiple players. And so you have
standard tool calls like call a function
that's deterministic, but then you
basically are having the model declare
its intent before it goes in. So it's
always outputting JSON. And you have a
little bit more um focus on basically
this this string of what do we want to
do next versus do I want to call a tool
or or say something to a human. Does
that make sense? I think you're saying
almost the right thing. And just like
really clarify, I know we keep saying
like JSON. What we really mean is we
just we're just outputting some specific
structure that we want. There's many
ways to do the structure. Yeah. Like
JSON is one technique that a lot of
people know commonly, but there are
other techniques that can make it
better. But I think what like
representing everything with as a tool
of like intent and giving the model some
way to go do that, then definitely yes.
Yeah. Cool. And there's no such Carlos
as a great question. Can a human be a
tool? So it's universal. There's no such
thing as universality with the world of
LMS. There's no when when you go to
Google search and when I search for like
how do I print a string, how do I do
like a print statement, I use a lot of
Rust code. Google will show me mostly
Rust results. When when someone
anonymous goes and search, it'll
probably show them Python or JavaScript.
There's no universality. And for your
users and your tooling, you might be
using the most average tool. So maybe we
can just call it a human. But the more
specific you can make it, the more
control that you are taking over your
system, the more accurate and a better
experience you'll provide to your users.
But it's all about testing and
iterating.
Anyone the best tool is is probably not
correct because they just don't have the
data for your use case. Okay, we got
five more minutes for slides and then
we're going to jump into code. So, I'm
going to fly through some more of these.
Um, control flow. I mean, we we've kind
of hinted on this a lot, but basically,
if you own your control flow, if you own
that switch statement, you can decide
when to break out into another workflow,
when to pause and resume later, when
these are all kind of like complement
each other. But the idea is you can pick
two or three of them at a time and start
incorporating them. And so, if you own
the switch statement, you can insert
little like modes to summarize things or
add an LLM as a judge to break out and
bring things back in. You can pause and
do something asynchronous and then
resume later. So this is this is kind of
we've gone over this one a little bit.
Another thing that I think I is is worth
mentioning is this like adding errors
onto the context window. If a model
calls a tool and that tool is bad,
either the API is down or it used bad
parameters or whatever it is. Um let's
say that result caused an error. We can
put that on the context window and hand
it back to the LLM and have it say like
let's try
again. And then maybe that will give it
enough to get to success. super s simple
concept. Almost every framework already
does this. Um, but that's another
interesting one that we talk about a
lot. Uh, the next one is kind of small
focused agents. Again, the longer and
bigger you have this like workflow owned
by the agent. Um, the more tools you
have and the more steps you have, the
more likely this thing's going to spin
out and fail. Uh, you may say like,
well, what if the agents get smarter?
Um, this is kind of how I see all this
progressing where you have a fully
deterministic workflow. You replace
small parts of it with agents and then
over time you can get bigger and more
interesting agents and they start to
overlap and maybe in a couple years say
what and I think this point what Dexter
is saying is that like when when these
principles that we're sharing here are
not just about like models getting
better like Sam Alman might tell you
that we have to go wait for the better
model it's going to go do everything but
that just means that the box gets bigger
like this visualization shows.
Yeah. And I think remove the need for
the box. Yeah. And I think even as the
as the models get smarter and you can
get better results with less
engineering, there will always be tips
and tricks that will help you get more
out of a given model. And I think the
Notebook LM team put this really well. I
haven't seen anything on Notebook LM in
a while, but when they launched it was
super popular. And the reason why it was
is because in their own words, the only
way to create really impressive or even
like magical experiences in AI is to
find something that is right at the
boundary of what the model is capable of
and get it right consistently. And so
even as the model gets smarter and you
don't need to do so much engineering, if
you want to do something that is 10x
better than what already exists, you are
going to want to do some engineering and
you want to have the flexibility to to
be intentional about this. And to give
everyone like an analogy that I think is
relevant to like current software is
technically most websites are really
just the same thing the different views
on similar databases.
the way people interface with it makes a
huge difference and because it just way
that you re like react to a site and the
way that you see the data the same is
going to be your agentic systems like
we're all using the same models quad
code versus cursor they're both using
sonet 37 there's no difference it's just
the the UX and all the engineering in
between exactly that is the only thing
so like if you want to make a
differentiated product there's no moat
and saying, "I'm going to use the best
model." Everyone has the best model. You
assume that and assume people have a
better model than you. Yeah. Make a
better product anyway. And do that with
engineering.
Cool. Um, all right. We're going to
speed through the last few of these. So,
um, yeah, factor 11. Trigger from
anywhere. Meet users where they are. I
think, uh, chat GBT is the like geo
cities era of like AI UX's. There's
going to be a lot better ways to
interact with AI. Um, I think a lot of
people who are building really
impressive things are building AIs that
you can interact with fully from your
email inbox, from Slack, um, from lots
of places beyond just a web application.
And this one's a bit of a meme, but it's
kind of the the culmination of
everything else that we've been talking
about, which is, you
know, LM are stateless, agents can be
stateless, you're just operating on a
context window. And uh actually someone
commented on LinkedIn. I think it's
actually because there's multiple steps.
It's a transducer, not a reducer. But uh
that's that's kind of a good summary.
Maybe. All right. We can get into that
one later. One second. I just want to
appreciate one thing for everyone. Can
we appreciate that the naming that Dex
used was hex code? That is amazing.
Well, I wanted it to sort. I wanted it
to make sure. No, I get it. I get it.
So, I want everyone to just appreciate
that. All right. quick little thing and
then can you go to the to the browser
really fast your uh drawing thing I just
want to draw the whiteboard yeah someone
asked a really good question that I
think is relevant and going to help us
out so the question someone asked um
Jonathan asked like what's the advantage
of using small number big agents versus
a large number of smaller agents and I
think the analogy that everyone should
use is that these systems are really
about like we these systems are all
fallible they fail all the time so let's
look at if we use a small number of big
agents you end up with a curve curve
that looks like this. You have some
distribution of how well it works and
you have a wider array of things that
you might work well on, but you also
have a wider array of things you will
work poorly on. If you use a large
number of small agents, then you
basically change the distribution to
look like this. You'll work better in
certain areas and you may not work as
broadly. But if you build it really
well, you can actually make a curve. If
you the more engineering you put into
it, you can basically change that curve
into something that looks like this. You
can make it wider and taller as you
wish. And that's really the difference.
It's like the amount of engineering
effort you put into it. The orange curve
is no engineering effort. Let the model
do everything. The green curve is some
engineering effort. The red curve or
pink curve, I can't see on my screen's
pink is is more engineering effort. And
that's how you scale up these systems.
It's like databases. The way you make a
database go scale to like five nines is
you just put more engineering behind it.
You can make it really damn good. It
just uh amount of engineering and same
thing is true here. Hopefully it answers
Jonathan.
Awesome. All right, let's write some
code. Let's write some code. This is my
favorite part. Um okay, cool. So, uh
what I have here is a empty TypeScript
project. Um, we're gonna do TypeScript
today because I wanted to coin flip and
uh we've been doing a lot of Python
lately. So, uh, what I'm gonna do is,
uh, I'm gonna just start grabbing files,
uh, for this walkthrough. We're going to
start with just a really simple, uh,
hello world. So, literally, here's our
script. I can run it with, uh, let make
that terminal a little bit
bigger. Um, so if I run this script, uh,
it just prints hello world, right?
Great. We can commit that. That's all
we've That's all we've done so
far.
Um, sorry. Um, the next thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to install BAML,
which is what we'll be using for
prompting our agent and building our
determine next step prompt. Um, and
there is one default file that comes
when you do that BAML in it. That is the
resume that I'm going to uh close out.
So now we have in our BAML source we
have clients which is things that talk
to LLMs and then we have generators
which is some BAML config. I'm going to
write a really simple agent here um that
basically just has one tool call which
is we'll call it done for now but it's
basically respond to the user.
Let's yep. So we have a prompt called
determine next step. Um, and it is
basically can return one type which is
done for now where the model will
declare its intent and then we'll just
get the message that it wants to send.
You want to zoom out a little bit? Yeah,
there we go. Cool. There we go. And do
you want to click on open playground so
people can just read the prompt fully
for that one test case a little bit
better? Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. There
you
go. So, um, the system messages you're a
helpful assistant. We'll go in and show
you how like we'll, as an example, we'll
add reasoning and some fancy stuff to
this prompt. We'll add more tools and
types to it. Um, but you can basically
say, hey, you're working on this thread.
If we wanted to test this or play with
this, um, you know, we can run it and it
says, hey, here's our answer. So, if we
wanted to give it other instructions
like talk like a pirate,
save this and we can run it again. And
now it's going to talk like a pirate.
Great. And I want to highlight this.
This is one of your factors. Respond to
agents with tools. Instead of having it
just respond as a string, we could
change the return type of determine next
step to not be deter done for now, but
instead be a string. Can you make that a
string type? And press play. We could do
this. Like that's totally a valid way to
do this, but by using a tool, we're able
to get a couple of wins for users, which
is now we can just render the message
field to the user. Exactly. Um, so I'm
going to generate the uh models for this
uh the TypeScript code for this and then
I'm going to enable the BAML debug
logging and I'm going to add a couple of
TypeScript files. So we're going to add
we we're going to add a CLI which
basically just pulls a user message off
the command line, turns it into this
thread object that we'll get into a sec
and sends it to our agent. And then our
index.ts TS is going to call that CLI
function. Um, the agent itself is pretty
simple. I'm going to start here. This
this is called agent loop. This actually
doesn't do any Oops, sorry. Close that
out. This doesn't do any looping yet.
It's just going to call our determine
next step and then it's going to uh
return it. Um, we have this thread
object which is just a li list of
events. Um, which we'll get into, but
this is like the items in our context
window. And so when I run this quickly,
I'll show you
um if we can say
hello, what happens is we have kind of
the BAML logs will actually output the
prompt that was passed in. So here's the
thread we actually gave to the agent in
our determine next step prompt. Um we
serialize that for the agent and then uh
so we build this thread and it gets
passed in as JSON and then we ask it
what the schema should be and it says
cool. So I can say, you
know, hello, talk like a
pirate, this is the best the best LM
example that exists. There we go. So now
it output this thing and we just kind of
print it out. So that's our that's our
literally natural language to tool
calls. The only tool right now is done
for now, but um we'll add more tools in
a sec.
Um Carl, while you get your next step
set up, I'll describe Carlos as like
BAML code is interpreted. So, BAML code
is just uh code that you write and then
we use that command line tool that
Dexter ran BAML CLI generate to convert
BML code into native TypeScript code.
Yes. So, if I if I were to actually use
the native like uh VS code clickth
through, you can see here's the
generated code that got generated from
this function. Yeah. And u people might
be wondering like why the heck do you
use BAML for this? Um yeah, go ahead. uh
you should probably tell them but like
the main reason I think Dex and I first
met is one we're just YC founders but
two the part about BAML that makes it
easier for people is just that it gives
you full control over the prompt like
the fact that the entire prompt is
accessible to Dexter and he can see it
and modify there's no default things
built in the prompt is where the is
where like why it becomes useful and I
think as we do unions it's going to be a
lot more interesting so let's go on to
the next part yeah and if you yeah if
you come back over this and you go watch
the recording. Watch this and then go
back and watch the We've already done
factors one, two, and three. And we're
about to do factor 4. Yeah. Um
demonstrated in here. So, um we'll
commit that. Here's the kind of diff of
everything that we did. Um so, now we're
going to add uh what I'm going to call
the calculator tool. And so, this is
just uh again a bunch of structured
outputs defined in BAML. That is the add
tool, subtract tool, the multiply tool,
and the divide tool. Um pretty simple
stuff. And then what we're going to do
is we're going to update our agent.baml
to return either done for now or
calculator
tools. That's it. Um did you define
calculator? Oh, we need to Yeah, there
we go. Oh, it's calculator tools plural.
That's why. Okay, cool. Um and so if we
regenerate our our code here, um there
now we can ask the agent. We're not even
going to change the TypeScript code.
We're just changing the basically by
changing the tools that gets passed into
here, it changes our prompt. And so this
is just prompt engineering right now.
Yeah. Um and so now you can see the
prompt is going to ask it to answer in
any one of these schemas. So I can run
and add it. And uh again, we're not
actually doing anything with this
output, but this is factor one. We turn
natural language into a structured
object that says add three and four. And
this is like the most important part.
We're the lime remember is not calling
the tool. It is simply returning a data
model that I then interpret as a thing I
can do something with. It's like any
other API call. It's just a stateless
API call that we were able to convert
the model into. Yep. So here's the only
change we made is we added tools and we
told the LM it can return those tools as
well. Yeah. Um now let's actually go
process that. Um
so I'm going to update our agent.ts.
And essentially now we've updated this
to have a full what we call like agent
loop
where yeah okay that looks
good. Did we not generate? No I think it
did just there. You probably just didn't
generate there. Okay. Um so now we're
going to get our next step out and we're
going to do a switch statement. We're
going to say if it's done for now we'll
just return the message. If it's add
then we're going to compute the result
one. we add that to our context window
and I'll show you what that looks like
as we go through and then we're going to
push the result onto the context window
and we're going to loop again to the top
and we're going to just check now with
our new thread what's the what's the new
next step
so while Dex runs this and executes this
like one thing to think about is we all
see these frameworks we all see like
lang chains tool calling API we all see
agent api uh we all see like um the
openai API SDK they're all doing this
loop. They're just not giving you
control over the loop. Own the loop. Own
the loop. That's it. It's not that hard.
Um, so here's here's we we passed in our
first prompt and we got out the intent
was add. And then we printed our next
step and our tool response was seven.
Um, we'll turn up the logs in a second.
This will make a little bit more sense.
And then here's the next context window
we put in. We just said display to not
be so dark by chance. Is that possible
in your terminal?
Uh, I was trying to get it better
yesterday. I actually changed a bunch of
my colors to work better with the BAML
output colors. Uh, but you all need a
solarized theme. I will apologize for
that. Uh, ANC color art is very poor as
I've learned. Maybe like black. Yeah,
it's not good.
High contrast. Oh, yeah. There you go.
Uh, you know what? I can't change the
profile of an active shell. Oh, okay.
Never mind. Go on. Sorry, folks. Um, you
can run this code yourself in whatever
show you want though. Um,
so let me turn this off and I'll just
show you kind of how we're logging this
stuff out. Um, can turn it back on. Oh
yeah, we can turn off the log. That's
actually better because then we can see
the tooling part of it. Yeah. So this is
this is just our logs that our
application is printing. And so I asked,
you know, can you add three and four and
then add six to that result. So it it
emitted this attempt. We gave it this
result and then it tried to add them
together and then it gave it this one.
And then we have done for now and it's
good. And you could easily see how we
could build a UI off of this. Like
pretend that this isn't even an outline.
I think the most important part of the
Grock is this doesn't have to be an
outline. I just have a machine that is
outputting events and now I can build a
UI on top of this whether it's a chat
pro chat system or anything else. And
that's all this ends up being.
Um, cool. I'm going to break this uh and
ask it to subtract things. Um, because
we haven't actually implemented we've
only implemented add. So, if it's not
done for now or add, we're just going to
blow up with, you know, unknown intent.
We don't know what that intent is. So,
I'm not going to make you all watch me
code out the handlers for all of these,
but we'll basically pull this into a
function called handle next step. And
that handles add, subtract, multiply,
divide. And so now our loop becomes
determine next step, add that to the
context window, and then handle next
step. So, if it's one of our break-in
conditions, we'll just return. But if
it's one of these four, um, we'll fall
through the switch statement and we'll
do handle next step. And this handle
next step is basically going to append
the thing to the thread and then return
it. That make
sense? So now we can ask it to subtract
three from four. And now we can ask it
to multiply three and
four. And now we can ask it to do big
complicated things like add and multiply
and divide and uh run through all
this. So that's tool calling loop.
There we go. We now we own our control
flow and we can do lots of things. The
the idea of like when we the control of
when we break and return versus when we
continue and loop through I think is
really important and interesting. So
let's let's look at this code a little
bit just so people can see this a little
bit better. Yeah. What do you want to
look at? Just like describe maybe we
should describe to people exactly what
we're doing. So like how are we doing
this? So so our CLI comes through and
takes the input message. We build a
thread with that message and then we pop
and then we hand that off to the loop.
So that's our base
thread. We pass that thread into the LLM
and I'm going to get into testing as the
next thing. So we can actually look at
what some of these prompts are returning
and stuff. But
um yeah, we pass that into the LM. We
get back a next step. Um, when we push
our results on, we want the LM to know
not just what was the result, but also
like what did I call because the LM
doesn't know that it called it. When you
pass the context window back in again,
it only knows what we tell it. And so,
we want to be able to tell it, hey, you
called a tool that is this next step
that is this
um, you know, you called this intent
multiply 34. We can turn on the BMA logs
again so people see the full prompt as
well. the next time it run. Um, actually
what we're going to do just for time,
I'm just going to do it in the test
instead. Oh, better. Um, so I've added a
couple tests to this file. So here's a
math operation here. Um, and so we can
uh pop through here and run this test.
And so basically the prompt that we put
in was, you know, your helpful
assistant, here's the user input, what
should the next step be?
Um, cool. Uh, and then the output was
multiply three and four. Carlos, that's
a great question. Like, why doesn't the
LLM know what tool it's called? Unless
you put something into the context
window of the model. It doesn't know
anything. So, I could have gotten the
answer of maybe add a test case. Ed, do
you have another test case that you want
to add in? Uh, I have a bunch more test
cases. Go on. I'll let you go do that.
All right. All right. Cool. Just just
for the sake of time. Um and happy to
kind of do follow-ups and if people can
we can we have time blocked after if
people want to hang out for questions.
So we can run these tests now. Um we can
also do add what's really interesting
here as far as like being able because
your context window and your input is
just a string. We can make assertions
and basically build really simple evals.
dinga um
and like make assertions about what
the model returns for certain inputs. So
if I change this to add and I run the
test again, this is going to
fail. Um so I can run this every time I
make a change to my prompts. And then we
can also make assertions that like all
right, cursor doesn't know this yet, but
that's fine.
Um so we can make assertions about the
whole thing that the model outputs. Um
and the important part here is like we
don't need LMZ val like when you use
structured outputs you stop you l val
still might be useful but for a lot of
use cases I just need to know that the
intent was correct and the parameters I
got out were correct. That's what I need
to really nail down.
Yeah. So uh let's let's do a test for
the long math thing and this will get to
kind of what you were asking for before.
I'm going to turn the logs back on just
so I can see the prompts that are
getting put in um as it's going through
this. So by the end of this we have this
really long kind of thread as our
prompt.
[Music]
Um and since it's just strings, we can
have cursor format this however we
want. Great. Um, so, so this is what
we're passing into the model on that
last thing. And if we run this test,
we'll see that the output was, "Hey,
we're done." And we got our final
result. But, um, if we took like a
subset of this and we said,
um, let's do you want to remove the tool
response. Yeah, exactly. Um, let's
format this again. Live coding, folks.
And this is like another thing that
Dexter was talking about like you need
to be able to test like we no one knows
what's the best thing for your system.
The only way you can know is to actually
just run the test and like so here's go
ahead Carlo question of like oh sorry
one last thing Carlo has a question like
doesn't know what tool it's called if I
that's what I'm gonna Yeah. Okay cool go
for it go for it. Sorry. Yeah. So I
actually so let's let's just rewind this
a little bit and let's say that we take
away this tool call. So instead of
telling it um I mean it might be smart
enough to figure it out but basically if
we just put the tool responses
in I have no idea what this is gonna
say. I've never tried this. I don't
know. I don't know. I think you but this
is the point is like you should be able
to try everything and you should be able
to see like actually it doesn't matter
the model for a calculator app the
model's smart enough to figure out that
we want to add these things. So multiply
three and four and then add 12 to that
result. Correct. So I think it actually
figured it out in this case because it's
a simple problem. Yeah. And the model is
What model are you using? Can you show
the prompt again? This is uh GPT40.
Okay, cool. Yeah. So, GT4 is try
switching it to Mini and seeing if Mini
it up. But,
um anyways, I hope that answers the
question. Um I'm going to keep rolling
just so that we have more that we can
get to all the topics. Yeah, I want to
talk about the more interesting stuff
you have lined up, too. I know we only
have 10 minutes, so let's keep going.
Cool. Uh, if I can get my shell back in
the right place, we can roll. All right,
cool. Um, so here's like the actual like
big pile of tests. And now we have a
bunch of them. So, let me hide the
playground here.
Um, and so this has like five or six
longer tests. And I can do npx panel CLI
test. And so as we're building this, as
we find things we want to change our
prompt, we can go through all of that.
So I'll commit this again. And in this
chapter, all we changed was
agent.baml.l. We just added a bunch of
tests. We didn't write any TypeScript
code for that
chapter. Um, cool. Let's add another
human tool. So, this is where we talk
about having multi different reasons to
contact a human. There may be a model
saying, "Hey, I need to request more
information." Or there may be like an
intent that is like, "Hey, we're done.
We have the final answer." And your code
might want to handle those things
differently. um either display them
differently or have different workflows
or put in a text box for them to fill
out, whatever it is. Um if you have
control over stuff, then then you can do
it. So, I'm going to regenerate off of
this and we're going to see how that
works. So, what I'm going to do is I'm
sorry, go ahead. Auto regenerating every
time you hit command S anyway. Oh, yeah.
That's true. Anyway, that's fair. Um I
was running this walkthrough from
scripts and stuff, so it didn't have it
in there, but that's fair. Um, so I'm
going to ask it, can you multiply three
and a bunch of garbled nonsense? And
it's going to request more information.
Actually, it's going to keep going over
and over again because we're not
actually handling this in our TypeScript
loop yet. We don't have a case in our
switch statement for this one. But you
can see it's at least output the intent.
It looks like there's some in incomplete
information. So I'm going to come in
here and update our agent and basically
say, you know, in this case, we're going
to handle them the same, which is just
to return the message. and they both
have a field called message. But you can
see us handling those two things
differently. And we're actually able to
use like the static analyzer there. So
that way like TypeScript can tell us
that they both have the same field
message. If you hover over message like
it knows TypeScript isn't yelling at
you because the intent of request
information has a field called message.
Yeah. Because we're in this part of the
switch statement, TypeScript knows that
it's either one of these two things.
Exactly.
Um, cool. And then I'm actually going to
tweak this a little bit more where we're
going to actually have this return the
whole thread. And we'll see why we do
that in a sec. But basically, we want to
know in our CLI whether uh when we run
the loop, we want to know whether it was
request more information or final
answer. So if it's final answer, we're
just going to print it on exit. If it's
request more information, we can
actually like write a function that is
like ask human. In this case, it's just
on the command line, but um this is how
you can take two ways that the model may
want to contact a human and handle them
differently. Dex, can we slow down for
one second before we run the code and
just show the show the data models one
last time just to make it in the in the
in the source code? Yes, in here. Yeah,
let's let's look at like what these
messages are. So, we have a class called
clarification request which has an
intent attached to it called request
with the label request more information.
And then there's another class called
intent uh with intent done for now. And
if you look at the prompt, can we render
the full prompt in the prompt view?
Yeah. Just so people can read it because
I think there's a couple questions about
this. And let's just like hide the test
at the bottom. Yeah.
And let's just like read this. So you
can see the model is kind of letting us
output one of those tools because on
line 19, what Dexter has said is that
the model can respond with two different
ways. Can you respond with human tools
or calculator tools? And can we hover
over human tools? Oh, yeah. Human tools
is defined as we don't hover. Oh,
whatever. Human tools defined as
clarification request or done for now.
So, it must be one of those two data
models. And if you can you change the
data model instead of request more
information to be like request fu just
so people can Yeah, just I think Carlos
is having a go down. Just change the
line instead of intent. Use the word
like intent. Fu fu. Yeah, just change
that string. really briefly. So you can
see that the prompt is updating to mimic
that. That's how the model is getting
this. We're just writing code and the
code is being added to your
prompt. Um and that's how the model is
able to go. You can undo your changes.
Yeah, don't do that because but you can
do your changes. And then if you scroll
down one more time into the prompt, uh
one last thing I want to show ctx format
that is you remove that line really
fast.
Yep. That is what's actually adding the
instructions into the prompt. And if you
add it back, that's all that's doing.
That is taking the return type of the
function and injecting it into the
prompt for you. And so that's a nice
BAML BAML feature that is basically,
hey, based on your return type, what
should what should we tell the model to
output? And then we're just letting the
model do the magic. The model is kind of
telling us what to go do. Yep. Let's go
on. Perfect. I'm going to restore us to
where we were. Yep. Um, so we have our
our loop and stuff. Basically, if the
model outputs this request more
information, we'll ask for info on the
CLI.
Uh, you might want to regenerate. Sorry,
I think you did a Oh, because you we
updated the file and you hit command S,
but then Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. So, yeah, now it says uh request
more information. I could say use 12
instead.
And now when it's done, it still exits.
So we're handling these two different
requests to for info in different ways.
This is really cool. And like just for
someone just to reemphasize this point.
This is how you in your chat agent that
you're building. You could do this in a
website too. Can you go back to your
loop code that you're doing where you're
actually getting read line like where
you're actually making? Yeah. Exactly.
If we have time today, we only have five
minutes, but if we have time, we can
actually instead of using a CLI loop, we
can make this a web API that is either
synchronous or async like this. The
agent is the agent is decoupled from the
UX so that you can plug this agent into
multiple different interfaces.
Exactly.
And the input to the agent is just a
list of events and the output is
last event that was exactly what what's
the next step and it's up to the
framework can handle it. In this case
it's actually not it's not the last
event it's the full event thread. Yeah.
because then we when we add a when we
get a response from the user we get the
response and that is now coming from um
it's coming from
um just to be very it's coming from like
CLI but it could come from a web API it
could come from a database request it
could come from an event on Slack
doesn't really matter it comes from
somewhere and then all we do as Dex said
is boom we just pass it back to the
agent loop again on line
29 that's all we're really doing? Yep.
And so then we just we do it we do it
once and then we loop until we get the
done token. Exactly. This could actually
be more clear if we did like not equals.
Yeah. But we can for now optimization.
Um anyways, uh I'm going to add some
test cases for this behavior because I
think it's cool. So now we can see, you
know, if we pass in nonsense and I'm
actually going to change this one to be
not hex because sometimes it sees hex
and gets figured it out. And that's just
testing. Like the only reason you know
that is because you tested that. Yeah.
It's nonsense. It's insufficient. It's
like, oh, it's too smart. It thinks it's
it's it will actually think it's u Yeah.
X code. So, so we can add evals and
guardrails. Now, we make sure if the
math is garbled, it must request more
information. That's what we expect the
agent to do. And if someone changes the
prompt in a way that breaks that, we
will know before that gets merged in
because the unit and then here's one
that shows how it interprets the
clarification. Right? So we gave it some
garbage and then we said you know uh the
model called the tool which was like hey
can you clarify this and then the human
responded with let's try 12 instead and
we can test this one and we can see like
okay cool now it's going to it like
listen to the human's feedback and we
can prove that we're passing the human
info back into the model in the right
way. Um so let's run all of our tests.
While you do that I love the word that
you use. You use the word prove because
that's really what it is. You want to
prove to yourself that it's working.
Yep. So, one of our tests failed. Um, it
was our hello world step. So, now we can
see, okay, we changed our prompt by
changing the structured inputs, but it
broke one of our other tests. So, let's
go look at this. Sometimes you break a
test and it's because you changed the
behavior intentionally, and sometimes
it's because you actually broke
something. So if we just say hello to
the model now that we're telling it that
it can respond with either done for now
or request more information, it's
actually decided that if it doesn't know
what to do, the correct intent is
request more information. So to maintain
this and keep it up, I'm going to come
and update this test because I actually
think that is also the correct answer.
It's like the conversation is still
ongoing. And now we can run this and we
can see that it passes. And by the way,
we could have decided that wasn't the
case and we could go back and change our
prompt for what request more information
means. Can you go back one last one on
one? Go up really fast. Yeah. You want
to change I want to change one prompt at
the top. At the top for your No, no. For
your request more information. Yeah. Add
a description to there. The description
says to clarify mathematical equations.
Yeah. Yeah. To clarify math
stuff. It's a dumb prompt, but like it's
just math stuff, right? Yep. Now, let's
see what the hello test does.
Um, okay. Still still request. It did
actually change what it said about a
math problem though. It said y to
clarify existing math problems.
Do
not so you can come and you can hear
come here and mess with this and you can
write tests. But this is a really
productive way to make changes and
improve your agents over time without um
without losing without losing steam. We
have one minute left. I'm going to power
through the last bit. Uh, inv you got 15
20 minutes to go over for people who
want to hang out. We'll stay over a
little bit because I u it sounds like
we're getting some really good questions
and we're we'll record the whole thing
and post it on YouTube as well. So,
including the Q&A at the end. Yeah,
folks have to drop. We'll have the
recording of the Q&A. Um, cool. So, now
we fixed all our tests and I'm going to
get out and commit this and quickly we
can review the changes we've made. So,
um, what do we do? We added
clarification request. Um, we changed
the type of our return to include both
of the human tools. We added a couple
tests for the using the clarification
stuff. We updated our test here so that
it passes. Um, we changed our agent loop
to return the whole thread instead of
just the
message. And then we updated our CLI to
kind of power that interactive loop a
little
bit. Cool. Um, now we're going to get
into some fun stuff. These the next two
are really quick, but they're really
worth doing, which is like customizing
your prompt with reasoning. Oh, yeah.
Um, so I'm going to add I'm going to
update our prompt here that we use and
basically just give it this um, you
know, always think about what to do
first, like, you know, these steps.
This, if you watched our reasoning
episode last week, um, this should look
very familiar. If you haven't, go check
it out. But this is a really easy way to
get small models to think and perform
more like reasoning models. So from
here, why you run this code. Um, yeah, a
lot of you are like, why the heck are we
doing dot dot dot? Like what what is
that? That's not really reasoning. Turns
out these models are really really good
at just what we want to tell it is the
structure of how we want it to reason.
In some ways, some format that it might
use. Yeah. And it to go do things. We're
not tell we're not going to prescribe
what it should reason about in any
meaningful way. That's why we're not
using few shot examples. That's why
we're not doing anything. We just want
the model to be like reasonable on its
own.
So, I'm going to pass in a little prompt
here and I'm going to turn on the logs
temporarily. What? Oh, sorry.
You have like Oh, I like that was it was
like trying to do a git operation. I was
like, why are you going to need my keys?
So, here we have printed out um
basically uh you know this and what
should the next step be and then we have
our reasoning prompt. Ah, see it was
working yesterday. Sometimes sometimes
it works, sometimes it doesn't. Can can
you use a can you uh the reason that can
make it a slightly more complex thing?
Um can can you add the can you add the
first four digits of pi together? Make
that the question that you're asking.
No, this prompt is fine. The prompt is
just too simple. The model first four
digits of pi. Yep. Now let's go do
that. So the model determined that it
doesn't need to reasoning at all. That's
why it didn't do it. But now so here now
it's done a bunch of reasoning here.
I will perform the calculation then I
should proceed. So now you have your
reasoning and
[Music]
then yeah each so it is reasoning each
time and there's probably some stuff you
could do to like cache that reasoning
basically. But
um here you can see it's outputting this
and then it has the final JSON here and
then what we pull out with BAML which is
also really cool is just like hey we let
the model output whatever tokens it
wants and then we rip out the actual
JSON and we get the answer. Yeah. So the
user doesn't even have to see the
reasoning. We just get that done for
now. And again I mentioned like oh you
could cache the reasoning and it's like
cool. There's all kinds of ways you
could do that now that you own the loop
in the control flow and customize how
you build your context window. You
nailed it. Speaking of which, let's
customize how we build our context
window. So, um, there are a lot of ways
you can optimize this. Um, but the first
optimization I'm going to make is just
instead of doing raw flat JSON like we
have been doing here, I'll just
stringify the JSON. Probably doesn't
make a difference for the model, but
this is just kind of a demonstration.
Um, so we'll turn on the logs again and
we'll give it this answer and we can see
over time. Definitely makes it more
human readable. So you can see over time
uh here's what was put in user input
tool call tool response tool call tool
response what should the next step be
here's your output and then it says cool
our intent is add and so you can see now
as the it's a little more clear like as
we loop through the context window is
growing and growing and growing but we
still get the same result we're we'll
talk about this a little bit more Carlos
and you want do you have any more
examples of how to serialize the L1
content yeah dude we have a really fun
one this is what I do when I build my
agents I use this thing that's a little
more um
XML. Um and so we have user input and
then as we loop through we have user
input and then we have multiply and then
we have tool response. The point is you
can do whatever you want to take that
list of events in your thread and
serialize it for the LM. So here we're
mapping it to this like serialize one
event function. Can you go back really
fast? I want to highlight something for
people because I think they might not.
Do you see what Dexter did here? He did
multiply a col 3 b col 4 and multiply
it. Can you compare that to the JSON one
that you had above? Oh, are we going to
do the token the token counting thing?
People should look at the tokens. You
don't have to We don't have Should I
drop Let me drop this in the Let me drop
this to the playground. Yeah, we should
do that.
Um, just add it to your test case. Yeah,
it's Yeah, this the serialization is
completely up to you. And if you don't
own it, you're Oh, sorry. I used
that word. We're recording. Uh, I'll
bleep it. But if you don't I already did
too. It's fine. If you don't own the
You'll fit right in. If you don't own
the serialization, you're really not
making life easy for yourself because in
this case, why are we wasting so many
tokens? Uh, yeah, let's just do the
prompt preview. Uh, okay, cool. So,
let's look at the prompt preview and
we'll look at the token view. So, this
is tokens one and we'll look at another
one already has JSON in it. So, we can
just compare these. So, token
visualization. Here we go. Oh, dang. We
don't highlight the tokens correctly.
Um, I'll fix the Hey, I don't think this
is right actually because I think the
XML is supposed to be really efficient,
right? No, no, it is. It is. We just
don't write render the escape characters
correctly. But just so people understand
is like go to the Can you go to the
OpenI tokenizer? I'll fix that, right?
I'll fix that in today's release
actually. Yeah. Um, is that like a web
app or something? Just go to OpenI
tokenizer. This is like one
serialization everyone should think
about is like we can use a serialization
technique of what um yeah that's
basically the view that we're supposed
to have. We just render the quotes the
things incorrectly slightly. Oh because
this is supposed to be HTML as long as
the fix HTML thing will be fixed. Uh so
I'll fix that today. But now post the
JSON view of it. You have a previous
JSON example as well in in your test
cases. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. So
let's get Yeah. This thing grab
anything. It doesn't matter. Yeah. Yeah.
And that's Do you see how every single
quote and everything that we're using,
every time that we put quotes in there,
it's extra tokens. Every time that we
put whites space in there, it might may
or may not be extra tokens. The count of
whites space matters um because we're
using like commas at the end. That's
extra tokens. So, there's small things
that are adding up. And these tokens are
not as trivial as like cost. People
think about costs. It's just the way
that you're explaining the thing to the
model. It has to If Dexter and I were
saying the word like and um every 30
seconds, you would have such a hard time
reading what we're saying. You'd have to
like do so much brain power to just
understand the nuances of our
words. There's just less likes and that
text. That's I love that metaphor likes
and that's great.
Um so you asked like ination
customizable. Yes, you can control it to
do whatever you want.
Yep. And so now we can add some tests
that kind of match this where we've
we've updated our tests to be XML
instead. And you can run these the same
and you can make sure like, hey, we
changed how we format our context
window. Do all our tests still pass?
Which is again what you should always be
doing. Every time you make a change, you
should know, okay, the the same input is
still the same output. Exactly.
Or yes. Cool. Um I think we can uh let's
we can do you want to pause for
questions here? Um or do you want to put
it behind a web server? I want to answer
um location's question of like how do
you build your first agent? This video
that we just made and all the source
code is going to be available for you uh
probably within like by the end of the
day today. So we'll send it out on
email. If you signed up on Luma, you'll
get the email. Um, this is probably
We'll also create a template repo with
this stuff in here so you can just kind
of pick up the calculator tools and
start running with it. Exactly. Um,
yeah. All the code we ever do will
always be open source for AI that works.
Like that's the premise. Like we just
want to share code so we can all learn
the best architecture designs together.
Uh, because as Dex always says, none of
us know what the right answer is. We
just wanna we all just need to figure it
out. And the best way to figure it out
is to
test. Um, let's let's let's uh how about
this? Why don't we take some questions
in the chat? While that happens, why
don't you do the web server stuff? So,
we'll paralyze cool. Web server stuff is
so freaking cool. Uh I me and you were
one of the first people to start
building out this kinds of things and I
think it like blew our minds as we were
building it out and then like it just
became the template for like how I think
we both think about agents. Yep. So if
you anyone has question, type it out.
Dexter is going to do some typing stuff
uh while that happens and then we'll uh
I mean that's it. That's the web server.
Oh, okay. Cool. So we put it behind an
API. Um what we can do is make this like
pause and resumeumable though. Um pause
and resumable. That'd be sick. So uh
here we have we I basically I won't go
in super in-depth on the code, but you
can go read it. We have a thread store
that kind of just stores our things in
memory, but this could be Reddus or
SQLite or wherever you want to put it.
And then we basically have this server
with an endpoint to start a new thread.
This code looks a lot like our CLI code.
Um, and basically if the last data
intent is request more information, we
add kind of a hook to it to basically
tell the client like, hey, when you have
a response to this, post it to this URL.
And then we have another endpoint that
can handle responses. For people that
are familiar like web interface, think
of it like a web hook. Like when GitHub
just you just register your web hook and
that's what we're telling the front end.
It's like when you get an update and it
doesn't have to be a front end. It could
be another backend service. It just says
when you're ready with the answer call
this API and we're just telling it.
So I called with this garbled you know
and XYZ and it's requesting more
information and it says hey when you
have the answer you know you can post it
back and so I will post this back and we
will use this thread ID here and and by
the way this is how we made like a
slightly uh stateful system but because
we save the thread system in our
database but we could may have made it
completely stateless by send object back
instead of a thread ID. we just did this
because it's it's a better API
experience for the end user uh and we
can do migrations on the thread and
everything else. But this context that
we're sharing here today is about owning
the loop. If you own the loop, if you
own the way that the model is being
called, you can build this trivially
because you can use existing paradigms
that you're already familiar with in
software engineering to build your
agent, not have to relearn like this LLM
voodoo magic to go build your agent.
That's all just software. It's all
software. I think we have another thing
that is like we'll I'll probably do a
follow-up or something on like, hey,
what if you have human approval, right?
You can have a tool like divide is
scary. We don't want to run that without
checking with the human because we don't
want to divide by zero error or
something. You have that up. You hit
show them. Uh, no, that's not ready to
go. I mean, we could try to live code it
for the for the extra linkers, but we'll
send it out. We'll send it out or maybe
we can do one a whole episode on just
that because there's so many nuances to
the way that you do human approval that
I think it'd be worth it does it does
get a lot more complex. Yeah. So, and
like this is so like what you saw today
was a lot around like these
infrastructure that we built. This is
the philosophy of BMW and what what
Dexter is going to share about this
human approval stuff is kind of the
whole philosophy behind human layer.
Like if eventually at some point we'll
want one lay layer of control that we
want because no matter how much
engineering we add around these systems
at some point just like in a normal
workflow you want a manual process to
approve it. I don't want my release to
be fully automated no matter how good I
am. I'm paranoid I have a human presence
to release it out so people don't get
versions of BAML automatically. It's
like a manual process no matter how good
our pipelines are. in your LM workflows,
you'll want that. And that's where I
think a tool like human layer really,
really, really shines because no matter
how much engineering you do, at some
point you want to process because you
want liability and other things built in
and that's the value.
Yeah, I think you nailed it. So, there's
much more here and we can get way more
advanced with this and like probably if
we do a follow-up on this, I know we're
gonna, by the way, we're going to take a
break for two weeks after this. Um, so
this has been the kind of first four
episodes of AI that works. We'll call it
season 1. We'll be back in what is it?
Three weeks from today. Three weeks from
today with season two. Um, in some point
in season two, we'll probably do a
follow-up on this and do like, hey, how
do I take my 12actor agent and put it
behind email or put it behind Slack and
deploy it to a place? Because if you
have this and you have these principles,
you can run your agent anywhere. You can
run it as a small component of a bigger
system. Um, and everything just works.
Go back to your server.ts.
Yeah. So, uh, read your server.
Sorry, there was a thing blocking my uh
my UI. Making this a Slack API, some of
you, I'm sure, are are familiar with it.
It's not that hard. Taking that web
request and making a Slack API is really
easy.
So, we're going to go into that and talk
about the nuances though with AI and
Slack because there are nuances that
become different there that are were
very very different than just like a
normal Slack API and that's what I think
like I've seen some of Dexter's work on
this. It's freaking phenomenal.
It's funny. Other questions from
everyone? By the way, I know we spoke
for a long time. It was supposed to be
an hour. We did an hour 15. So, I
apologize for taking 15 minutes extra of
your everyone's time. No, no, no, no.
Don't apologize. You're welcome. These
people got 15 minutes extra content.
That's right. Um, what questions do
people have if they have any? Feel free
to unmute and come on or just uh ask on
chat.
Cool. So, so you guys uh played around
with uh like uh the reasoning models too
and how does they perform here?
So, the beauty is Dexter, do you want to
screen share again? Oh, are we gonna Are
we going to switch? Are we going to put
on uh 03? Make an amazing model. Just
switch it to 03. The beauty is remember
the what you're doing here. Just go to
your agent.ts. Yeah. Yeah. Make your
agent just make it 03. Doesn't matter.
01. It doesn't matter. Like the way do
03 mini. I don't think I my verification
went through yet for 03. So, all right.
Then just do baml live. Yeah. Just run a
test case.
Uh let's see. easier. Sure.
And this is a little bit slower because
these models are slightly slower, but
now we got it. So it and you can see
called 03 mini 2025 131. So it's the
model you use is completely independent
of this concept. You can choose any
model of your choice and and you could
write this function with four different
models and run all the models through
the same set of tests. Exactly. So then
you and then you can and you might say
that hey as if I want to have like the
ad tool then I want if I want the ad
tool then I want um then I want to use
this model if I previously you can make
all of this dynamic and it's your choice
and I think a lot of people ask like how
good are people with like uh using
frameworks or anything any framework
that owns that while loop that essential
while loop and doesn't give you full
access to it it's like if you've ever
used So, uh, a CSS
library, a CSS library that doesn't give
you the raw CSS that you can just edit
in your code is way more painful to use
than shad CN where you can just like
have it in your code and edit it. And
that's actually this is I think when we
build more tooling around this, I
basically think what we need is shad CN
for agents. We need something that
scaffolds everything out for you with
some good opinions and a couple
different variations, but then it's your
code and you can do whatever you want
with it. You should wait till we release
packages for BAML. That's basically what
that is.
Sick.
Question for Steve. Got a question.
Uh sort of as an aside, but I noted a
lot of the philosophy you've done in
this series of where you say, "Hey,
expected output and then BAML extracts
it out." I was reading the new prompt
guide for 41 with more literal calls and
it basically sort of says don't do that
or you know a variance of that. I was
wondering your thoughts. Yeah. Bye Bob.
When are you running that new benchmark
to prove that BL's still better at
extraction? Here's the here's what I
would really say. You want to share the
BFCL thing? Uh do you want Okay, I was
gonna Yeah, I'll share I'll screen
share. There's a couple of things. Uh,
one I think um I think uh there's before
I screen okay I'll screen share. Um but
before I go really really into it I want
to I want I think one important thing to
keep in mind for these kinds of
concepts. Am I screen sharing? Cool. Uh
one important thing to keep in mind is
remember everyone's biases. So my bias
is obviously I work on so like be aware
of that. Um OpenAI's bias is they want
to lock you into their SDK. Be aware of
that. Open eyes SDK is very different
than Anthropics SDK. they really want
you to lock in because then you can't
move over. Um, and two, like it's
possible that um, it's definitely
possible that it's better, but
fundamentally it seems unlikely. And the
primary reason that it seems unlikely is
that is just like we run these
benchmarks and every time we run them,
it's pretty much come out in the same
way. Uh, which is what OpenI says is
don't add JSON to your system. And I
agree with them. Do not ask the model to
output JSON and JSON.parse it. That is
bad. That is really, really, really bad.
The model will mess up on JSON,
especially if you have a bunch of escape
characters and everything else. The
difference
is BAML doesn't actually use JSON. So
like in this case, don't
use
quotes around
keys. The model is extracting data from
an image.
It's not use you see it's streaming it's
not using JSON this is not
JSON right so the premise that's saying
that and you can see like it's pretty
complicated there's like there's a whole
string with ands and spaces and
everything it's still pull it out so and
the idea is that like the engineering
work to turn the thing on the left to
the into the thing on the right is not
something that you should do and like if
you are not going if you are not going
to write your own parser you should
probably just let like force the model
to output JSON. Yeah. So if you're if
you're not going to write do the work
that we did behind the scenes, I agree
that their thing is probably way better
than
JSON.parse, right? And if you're going
to do something more sophisticated like
for example like an idea of like
generating code,
uh write me a thing, write like watch
this. Write me a thing that generates
that takes in leak code questions that
takes in a prompt and generates code for
it and generate it takes in a uh text
and
generates Python
code. Right? So what I want is I want to
write an AI pipeline that can take in a
random thing from a user and like
generate some Python code for it.
So this will do its thing. And once
again, this just tool calling this whole
thing. Like what I did here was this was
tool calling that responded to this.
This is another tool call that's
generating actual BAML code for me. And
then this is separate tool call that's
generating the Python code to use that
BML code. These are all just tool calls.
And all I'm doing here when I go do this
is if I were to go and I'll do this in
profit because it's a little bit easier
to go see.
So really use these tools a lot, huh?
Huh? This is impress. You're you're very
quick with this stuff. I gota learn. I
got I got I got I gota jump between
these faster. So now it's going to go
run the code, right? So now it's going
to generate Python code. And check this
out. See how the model did it? It just
responded with a Python code snippet
afterwards as a markdown snippet and it
produced this out. So you're right, JSON
is bad.
But serializing it in a way that the
model can output things and I can go
parse it is useful. And this is getting
that point of like the model's been
trained on a lot more code in markdown
than code in JSON. And so if the model
wants to write code in markdown, you
should let the model write code in
markdown. And then that will give you
better results than constraining its
output and forcing it to use like slash
ends and saying, "Hey, you can't use new
lines." Because then every time the
model wants to output a new line, that
token is going to get zeroed out. and
all the other tokens which were all like
1% in the sampling, it's just going to
pick a random one of those instead. And
the chance that it picks slashn is like
very low. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Dexter nailed it. So open as guideline I
agree with. JSON is bad. Um but I'm
still not convinced that tool calling is
good because tool calling is basically
doing JSON in a forced way and there's
no way you'll get this large quality of
code out. And the model did this
naturally. This isn't me prompting in
any way. I just like the prompt says
this. This is all the prompt.
That's all. This is the web request
going into the model. There's no tool
calling, nothing else. And the model is
naturally able to say that the best way
I want to output these tokens. The
tokens that are best for me to represent
this data is this.
Yeah, that's some trash JSON. Good job
parsing. That's a good ass parser, dude.
That's a good ass parser. Cool. Um, I
gotta get running. Let's uh let me just
stay on for any more questions that
people might have and then uh I think
we're mostly done. We don't tell the
model how to out how it outputs. We do
we tell it the structure that we wanted
to go have and that's mostly it. So
whatever it outputs you your parser sort
of like um it mostly works.
We've processed like million tens of
million I don't even know like I have no
idea how many data models that we've
gone through at this point. we have but
and Dexter has pushed a lot of limits of
them with his tool calling systems a lot
along with a bunch of other companies
and it's made it um the benchmarks show
that it's good but would in different
LLM models sort of like lean towards
something different. Yeah. So you can
just use a different model and it mostly
works because it's a very unrestricted
parser and there's like you can read our
blog post about it and that'll probably
outline it a little bit better. That's
cool.
Um, any other questions for anyone else
left? I know there's just a few people
and then we'll call it quits and then me
and Death have uh other meetings to
attend to. So, what do you think about
the MCP and the agent development kit?
Uh, do you plan to use it in your uh
products or how do you plan to integrate
with with them?
You want to go first? Okay. This is uh
this is not on behalf of Dexter. This is
my personal opinion of it. So just to be
very very clear and I don't know what
Dexter's opinion is. I don't think we've
explicitly talked about this. It's
complicated. Um yeah I think all those
frameworks are basically just like API
calls around rest
endpoints. Um and like they have some
way to do REST
endpoints and I guess they've made some
decisions around it but I'm not yet
convinced that it's the perfect
decisions. I think like lang chain for
example was very hyped for a while and
clearly doesn't work because of
engineering constraints
um and not really because like I mean
there's value in lang chain too but like
langraph is I think more thought through
than lang chain is is for example what
I'd say think mcp is
uh I wouldn't build a company on it
today is what I would say
um I think it's in anthropic's best
interest for MCP to get adopted because
they're building UIs that everyone uses
and they want to have a standardized way
for people to plug into their UI with
them doing less work. They're kind of
using MCP as a way to build and
bootstrap an app
store is the way that I kind of think
about it. But I'm still not I think when
I look at code, what I look for is
beautiful code and that's where I decide
if something is good or bad. That's like
when I first saw React, it honestly felt
beautiful. Like it was like it's
actually really pretty once you
understand it and I don't look at it.
When I look at lang chain, it doesn't
feel beautiful. That's why I didn't like
it. When I look at paid AI, it doesn't
feel beautiful. There's things about it
that feel a little off. When I go look
at MCP, I have the same feeling. I don't
look at it and be like, "Wow, that's
beautiful
code." And that's kind of where why I'm
not personally like 100% bullish on
let's go do this today. It might prove
to be amazing, but I don't think it's
beautiful today. And be beauty is really
important in code, especially for
frameworks and systems.
Cool. Um, wait, no, I'm gonna give my
MCP rant and then you're up,
Carlos. Uh, I think it's I think
protocols are very powerful. I think we
saw a similar thing play out in the
Kubernetes world, which was basically
like you had this thing called Helm,
which was like super scrappy and didn't
have I think probably arguably all the
right abstractions, but it was at a
level that people could understand it.
it was good enough for people to adopt
and move on to the next thing. And once
it got momentum and everyone was using
it, it was basically locked in. And it
didn't matter that Google came along a
year later and released like a much
better solution for the problem, a much
cleaner protocol, much more well thought
for, a much more like engineer friendly.
It didn't matter. It had already taken
off. So we may MCP may be the thing that
we're stuck with. Not stuck with,
whatever you want to call it. Um, I
think REST is pretty good already. I
don't not 100% sure why we needed it.
There's a lot in it. Um, but we building
stuff on top of MCP. I want to build a
BAML agent that queries MCP tools and
pushes them into the context window as
tools because I'm curious how the actual
performance is because if it's an easy
way to consume APIs, then I will
probably use it. Exactly. Even if it's
not perfect. MCP is basically a REST
service that has a very specific query
that you can make that says tell me all
the other services you have. That's
it. And that sounds useful.
Yep. And oh, the other fun thing if you
want to uh if you want to mess with
people is, you know, MCP servers, most
of them are actually clients. They're
not servers. You don't call them over
the web. You you run them locally on
your machine and then they make the call
to a real server. But that's we won't
get it. That's just a naming thing.
Um any uh Carlos, you had one last
question. Yeah, you sort of answered
that question. I was going to ask
whether um the BAML can be integrated
with MCPAS and I guess um Dexter working
on it if you watch the first. Well, IAS
is is working on it a lot more, but we
should do an episode on that by Bob. We
should be like how do you how do you
great MCP with factor? Yeah. Yeah, we
should go do that. I think that'd be a
fun one. I think especially for like the
next season, we'll go one thing we're
gonna go do, uh, I know a few of you
left. We're gonna go send out a survey
at the end of this with this episode. If
you have time, we'd love like a detailed
response to it. It will just help us
tune the next few things and then it'll
start every Tuesday after that. And you
should expect to see this uh detailed
code examples pretty regularly with Dex
and I.
Amazing.
Thank you. It's been a blast. Thanks
everybody.
Um, and then we'll stop the recording.